make way for the Georgetown head coach
and friend of the show one of our
favorites
Patrick Ewing joining us here
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach manage you know it feels great to
be able to call you coach and it's a
head coaches a long time coming did you
ever think that it wasn't gonna happen
you know what I was prepared for it
not Sam but first of all wait before I
answer the question finally I get to is
not the man cave no it's not there's not
dimension I'm here in person we see it
we're low as seen each other face to
face it's great I actually I think might
have interviewed you back in 1980 three
or four I was there when you were
drafted so I mean you don't remember me
I remembered you though but I know it's
great to see and you still have the
invitation to come to the man cave and
play basketball I don't know if you're
gonna get my shot though well you know
what I probably won't cause my knee
still hurts when's the last time you
blocked a shot do you shoot around it on
do you miss any what do you miss about
the game you know what I don't miss
playing because I went straight from
playing into coaching so everything that
that goes into playing I was doing
except for going out and actually you
know playing I was you know using my
mind to you know getting the players
prepared I was going over game plans so
everything that is it takes to get the
guys ready except for going out and
physically competing I was doing so I
really never never missed it
though there was some times when they
were you know real big games you know
I'm sitting on the bench and I'm nothing
you know whoever I was next time like
you know I think I can go out and maybe
get I don't want to get like 30 and 20
tonight you know I might those days
might come
I would I would have those days I should
say but other than that I really never
missed it who do you miss playing
against you know what I'm not so if I
miss playing against them because you
know that in my era that the guys I was
playing against were were dominant
you know Akeem you know we had some
great battles you know you know I always
you know when I talk about the guys like
a cam or David or Shaq you know I always
talk about you know sometimes you get
the bear and sometimes so if you don't
bring your a-game
you know they they're they're gonna
dominate you so we had some fierce
battles against those guys but it was
fun they were fun I remember George
Gervin
I said who did you love playing against
and he said Kevin greevey
I said who did you love playing against
him George goes Kevin green he said as
soon as I got to town I knew I was gonna
get 40 did you have one of those players
that you went you know what I think I'm
gonna enjoy this night when I get to
this you know I never thought of anyone
like that because you know you had the
superstars and then you had some guys
that were unfair on you know we're at
that level so you know they were nice
when you when you came and you knew they
were they weren't at the same level as
you but I never really said I'm again I
just go out there and perform did you
ever say one night to your teammates I'm
gonna get 40 tonight oh there's been
many nights those guys
but did you get forward yes but how
would your game be now if your style in
the NBA or your style at Georgetown like
how how different a player do you think
you would be if you were going to
college I don't think it'd be any
different you would be a defensive
minded guy like you were when you
started your cell right you know I think
the game has changed definitely but you
still need players to still do the same
thing you know I think I'd still have to
play defense and I still have to be able
to score you know you still need someone
to block shots to protect the rim and
but I I was a player that did both
I laid defense and then I was still went
down out then and I scored you didn't
still need people rebound rebound both
ends you still need people to block
stocks
so I was able to do both and I I could
shoot I just didn't shoot out to the
three-point line the way that bigs shoot
now but I was capable of doing it I just
in my era I remember when I first came
to Georgetown coach Thompson
we played Virginia let's round Samsung
Sampson Ralph took a shot from about the
top of the key right here at the top of
the free-throw line right here and I
came down and took one from him from the
free-throw line and coach Thompson
called timeout he cursed me out his son
gets your bug in the paint but now it's
a different era it's a different era you
know big now what they want to shoot
threes you know and it's that's the way
the game has progressed and you know
people when I was in NBA all people are
always asking me where are the center's
and now the center's are the ones out
there shooting threes and the Dow under
guards are the ones are posting up so
would you be one and done at Georgetown
yes yeah yes or would have been probably
you know when they didn't have
the rule that you have to be one that
they're not probably would have went
straight from eyes could you do you
think you got could have gone right to
the NBA I could have I could have went
straight from ISIL when I when I came in
when I came in to Georgetown
okay I remember back then there were
there were the bullets I was a freshman
at Georgetown and back then the the
bullets they would come over and play
and play play with us and Mitch Kupchak
you know came over to me he's like man
you could you could play in the NBA
right now so I don't know what you're
doing how did you develop a great
friendship with Larry Bird you know what
it was it was it was it was strange it
was ironic because I hated the Celtics
growing up and you played in Boston I
grew up in Boston I didn't like the
Celtics
I was a Sixers fan and you know and
Larry and I got to be great friends
during the dream team and you know it's
funny uh he talked so much trash I
always talk trash talk trash on the
phone on the floor it was talking so
much trash during during the dream team
and that's how it started you know he's
always talking trash to me talking trash
to the rest of the players so I'm
talking trash back to him and it just
clicked you know we just always talking
trash to each other and started hanging
out you know going to dinner going to
lunch and you know just spending a lot
of time around each other and that's
what we just developed a very good
friendship
did he talk trash on the floor oh
definitely yeah you know I think I think
that story talked about X I think that's
one of the stories you got from me oh
yeah you might have got it from me but
you know he always talked trash
I remember in ages II talked trash
against us talk trash with everyone
against everyone else but you know the
difference is he could back it up he
could back it up you know I
you know like I was saying I've grown up
in Boston people all used to always talk
about that he can't jump he can't do
this he can't do that and you know a lot
of my friends was like that you know so
I you know I got to the lead I called
all my friends back up I said you know
all that trash talking you need to
squash all that this this man is great
he can whatever you were saying for a
man who can't jump heal the mic and
amaya is demolishing everybody so your
your guys are saying how can you let
this guy he's doing it on the best
defensive players in the league there
that's funny Patrick Ewing joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner first
year coaching at Georgetown what's the
biggest thing you learned you know I'm
still learning you know I believe that
you know you would ask the question
before about did I why did I think why
did it take so long and I was I was
saying that it I was given an
opportunity and I was happy that I've
been given an opportunity and you know
it might have taken long but it's here
and what I've learned is that you know
all as long as for as long as it took
all that time I was able to work on my
craft and got better and better and
better and prepared me for this journey
so I just I just looked at his as you
know it was just a journey and I just it
just took me this long because I was
just working on it and I just believed
that all that that all the time was that
it's just you know taking the class and
you know learning from all the people
that I was I would work to worked with
and just bet to better my craft but do
you find yourself channeling coach
Thompson at all with how he coached you
I think I learned from everybody and not
just coach Thompson you know you have
you know you have some Pat Riley in
there you have some Jeff Van Gundy in
there you have some Stan Van Gundy you
have some Steve Clifford you have some
Rick Pitino I think it's you just you I
I borrowed from everyone you have some
Mike Jarvis you have some Steve Jenkins
who was a guy who who taught me in the
eighth in the eighth grade so I borrowed
from everybody and yes there's this
there's a lot of John Thompson in there
you know I don't carry the towel on my
shoulder like like I said I was going to
but you know I believe that everyone
that that I played for coach width you
know Linda I borrowed a lot from them to
to get me to this point you're
recruiting it's gone pretty well it's
it's it's I'm not gonna say pretty well
as it's going and it's it's getting
there when it when it's when it's going
pretty well I won't be here sitting on
the stage you'll be do you still have
your Georgetown uniform no and if I did
I could not wear it do you have a framed
Jersey no I don't you know what and they
I think they gave me one but I don't
even know where where it said I move so
much weight you don't you don't care do
you collect memorabilia like you don't
your judge collect memorabilia but I do
it for that one I do I don't I don't
know we gotta get down they depth they
probably don't even know where is that
what other memorabilia like what other
you call it just jerseys but I ball my
nick jerseys have other players know I
don't have a you never asked for another
Jersey no even from Jordan no especially
not Jordan would Mike have given you a
jersey yeah it would have but you know
what I would never ask
you know maybe now I would but
man I wasn't even I wasn't thinking of
it well you're competing against this I
you know what once you went to the
Wizards then you could have asked just
like people probably wouldn't want my
Seattle SuperSonics how did you end up
like you and your career as a super Sun
know in my career as a magic magic
that's even worse you know we make
mistakes in our life make mistakes time
you know there's nothing wrong with
those franchises they're there they were
great places I enjoyed playing for
though for those places but I should
have stayed in New York yeah you know
but we all it's it's everybody has one
of those moments where they go you know
what I want to play one more year or I
can go here and play so you you had
those those moment I know what could
have still played is just that well with
with the Seattle situation sometimes you
get tired of hearing the rumblings and
the team is better off without him and I
don't I heard that for 15 years so with
New York it's time to you know they just
get tired of it they didn't realize how
much they they would miss you until you
left right I mean really that's what
happened with New York because of what
you meant to that franchise and how hard
you played and you were underappreciated
there's in New York Nick well you know
but they that's true but um I should
have sucked it up and stayed because it
hurt them and it also hurt me did you
guys like I always viewed do you guys
you and Berkeley I'm alone you must have
hated Jordan cuz he would win those
titles and you know in the prime of your
career and you're like you know damn it
Mike won another title here and then he
goes to play baseball and then Hakeem
gets a couple of titles there you're
just born at the wrong time
you sound just like him you know he
tells me that same story because I came
a kid one he beat us for his first for
his first title and anyone that I got
hurt and then shot he played against
Shaq for the second but Mike says you
were born at the wrong time night I say
that but he just I stepped away and to
give you a shot to get a ring I was with
him at a golf tournament and Jordan
started in on Barkley well that's him
you know I mean it was vicious there
were like six people sitting around a
table and chuck joked with Mike and then
Mike didn't joke back and then he goes
how many titles you got that's Mike then
he kept saying it to Charles Charles I'm
sorry Charles could start talking how
many titles you got Charles how many
titles you got I went oh boy that's his
that's his that's his ultimate comeback
you know he and he's always been that
way he's been that way from the first
day I met him he's all talk about
another person who always liked to talk
trash that's him it's great to see you
we're proud of you and you know what
you're just starting there Georgetown
restarting their Georgetown 15 and 15
this year and hopefully a good
recruiting class and we hope to see you
in the tournament next year I appreciate
you coming back you know I'm having a
basketball camp this summer Georgia and
you need to come on do you want me to
teach the kids how to shoot yes yes yes
come on cuz I can put on a clinic that
was my nickname there you go do you want
to block one more shot yeah the final
block of your career Paul II would love
for you to block one of
you think you could do that come on all
right Paulie wants to bring it you're
gonna bring it right to him
Patrick Ewing head coach at Georgetown
Continental Coach's Corner okay here we
go
[Applause]
the Jordan the Jordan great to see you
thank you you almost II almost got no I
don't Patrick doesn't want a piece of
Mick just movie outside oh I'm gonna do
like my hardened
[Applause]
it's the hesitation but we've got you
yeah thank you man good luck I because
that we'll talk soon that's your work
[Applause]
[Music]
Wilda I'm a Pat right now I need a
minute thank you see you next year for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]